[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a thai comedy romance film
called first kiss
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
is a 25 year old woman who has never had
her first kiss in high school she was
deeply in love with a popular guy named
om but he had a girlfriend pam saw was a
nerdy student so she always knew she was
not ohm's type still she would watch him
every day in hopes of someday becoming
his girlfriend but then ohm and pam both
moved to the u.s during their last year
of high school saw was so heartbroken
that she has not developed a crush on
anyone ever since deep inside she is
still waiting for a miracle that will
make om fall in love with her even
though she hasn't seen him in almost a
decade one day during a high school
reunion saw's dream comes true om who
has just returned from america joins her
party and shows extra interest in her
although nervous she asks him if he is
single and he affirms the two exchanged
phone numbers planning to go on a date
someday saw goes to the bathroom to
compose herself and jumps in excitement
her years-long wish is finally coming
true starting that day the two begin
dating om frequently drops her off at
work which saw's colleagues mohammed and
jen do not fail to notice they playfully
tease her for landing a handsome and
rich man the two know that she has not
had her first kiss and prepare her for
it their tips and tricks on how to kiss
better makes saw more nervous than she
already is that night while returning
home on the bus she sits by a high
school boy named bass an accident occurs
on the road outside that everyone gets
up to watch while trying to adjust bass
and saw accidentally lock lips bass
laughs it off but saw is horrified she
wanted her first kiss to be with the man
of her dreams but now that a high
schooler has stolen it she cannot help
but to be disappointed she throws her
phone at him in anger and storms off as
he laughs behind her at home she
registers that she forgot to ask for her
phone back she calls it from her house
number but bass refuses to return it he
playfully challenges her to find out
what school he goes to in order to get
her phone back the next day at school
his friends notice that he is distracted
bass cannot get the thought of the angry
bus lady out of his head then an
announcement on the speakers asks
everyone named bass to come to the
principal's office he joins the others
in the office and finds out that saw is
the one who called them she remembered
his name on his school uniform yesterday
he reluctantly has to give her the phone
back and is beaten by the principal as
punishment saw feels bad for him and
takes him to a local restaurant for
lunch there the two get into an argument
because bass keeps calling her auntie
saw urges him to call her sister but he
refuses to do it instead he settles to
calling her by her name as they chat saw
gets a call from om calling her to a
restaurant for a date a few hours later
she goes to the said restaurant and
finds bass at one of the tables he
claims that they happen to meet by
coincidence but saw knows he must have
heard her talking to om on the phone she
ignores him and sits down with her date
after dinner he drives her home and
tries to kiss her but as he gets closer
a street garland seller knocks on his
window and interrupts the romantic
moment um awkwardly drives away after
the encounter leaving saw disappointed
she then finds out that the garland
seller is none other than bass in a
frustrated tone saw asks him what he
wants and is ready to pay if that means
he will leave her alone but bass doesn't
want her money he wants to go out on a
movie date with her to get rid of him
once and for all she agrees the next day
she dresses up fancy to embarrass him
and make people believe they are not a
couple the plan works but a bunch of
teenage girls call her bass's mother
which only makes her feel worse bass
seems to be distracted by something he
pulls her to the side and shows her om
hanging out with another girl saw is
shocked to see the other girl is his
high school sweetheart pam um locks eyes
with her but acts as though he doesn't
know who she is bass reveals that pam is
his friend and when he saw saw on a date
with om yesterday he understood what was
up hence he brought her here to show her
ohm's true nature saw registers that her
first love has cheated her and is
heartbroken the next morning she tells
her colleagues about the incident they
feel bad for her until bass comes to
their office and pretends to be saw's
new man mohamed and jen are proud of her
for being on top of the dating game the
four of them go to lunch where om blows
up saw's phone with messages but bass
takes her phone away and doesn't let her
talk to him for her own sake when she
starts arguing he simply leaves with her
phone to get it back she dresses up as a
high school girl the next day and goes
to meet him at his school when bass
recognizes her he is pleasantly
surprised before giving her the phone he
asks her to skip classes with him she is
forcefully made to run away from the
teacher when she is not even a student
the two end up in the science lab which
brings back memories of saw's school
days since the lab's window has a full
view of the basketball court she used to
spend hours in the room watching ohm
practice suddenly the teacher arrives
looking for them the two sneak through
the tables and manage to run away again
after spending hours having fun around
the school saw registers that she left
her wallet in the lab she goes to fetch
it but bass refuses to accompany her
when she is alone in the lab he calls
her asking her to look out the window he
is standing on the basketball court
grinning at her he sings a cheesy love
song for her that makes her forget her
decade-long affection for om they meet
at the staircase where he plants a kiss
on her lips and asks her to date him saw
is a bit shocked but she agrees starting
that day the two board the bus together
return home together go on dates on the
weekend and have a lot of fun as a
couple muham and jen also like bass but
do not know that he's a high schooler
saw refrains from telling them scared of
how they will react but a few weeks into
dating him mohammed finds out through
facebook that bass is a 17 year old the
duo tries to make saw understand that
she has no future with him i'd say she
could have a future with him she just
shouldn't have a present with him by the
time he is ready for marriage they say
she will be on the verge of menopause
saw knew that she will have to face such
problems one day but she still dreads
having to talk to bass about this later
when they wait for the bus she tells him
about her concern bass discloses that he
has also given it thought and planned
out their entire life together he
promises to never look at other women
even when she gets older and doesn't
expect a child because they can simply
adopt all he wants is to be with her his
entire life touched by her words saw
starts to cry they walk to his home and
he invites her in to wash her face saw
agrees but is met with a surprise when
three men start beating bass as soon as
they walk in initially she tries to
attack the men but bass reveals that it
is his father and his bodyguards bass is
in the school's musical band which is
quite successful however his father
doesn't allow him to pursue music
believing it to be the cause of his
failing grades he made the bodyguards
beat him up because he was told that
bass attended a band practice that day
an embarrassed bass apologizes and
promises to return home after dropping
saw off but when they reach her
apartment he insists she let him stay
for the night because he is scared his
father will beat him up again bass lays
on the floor while saw takes the bed and
the two fall asleep while talking the
next morning she hands him the apartment
keys so he can return home any time he
wants muham and jen see her doing this
and assumes she and bass slept together
last night the two warned her that a
relationship will not end well and phil
saw's mind with a million doubts that
night at dinner saw tells bass that she
is having trouble meeting the deadline
of a new project but he doesn't even
understand the basic office terminology
it makes her realize that they might not
be as compatible as she thought they
were if bass doesn't know what a fax
machine is they just weren't meant to be
the next day at work saw is busy and
worried about the project home arrives
out of nowhere and offers help by
looking for freelancers who will do the
filing for her saw is shocked to say the
least om explains that he was never in
love with pam and was engaged to her
because of their son but now he has
broken up with her for good and once saw
back in his life she doesn't give him
any answers and he takes it as a yes saw
texts bass about ohm's arrival which
upsets him instead of returning to the
apartment he goes to his friend's dorm
room he is tense about his father's
henchmen looking for him all around and
plans to work as a pub singer to make
some money for the time being the next
morning he goes to saul's apartment but
sees her driving away with om still he
believes that she would never betray him
he goes to meet her at her work where he
finds om waiting for her in the lobby he
tells muham and jen that he is planning
to take her out on a trip for the
upcoming vacation bass overhears the
conversation and is furious he storms
off to his band practice where saw
happens to be waiting for him she tries
to reconcile but bass rudely asks her to
cut the act at night saw returns home
and prepares bass's place to sleep even
though he is not returning the next day
om invites mohamed jen and saw to a
restaurant but he arrives late with his
one-year-old because pam refused to take
care of him sa asks him if he still
loves pam but om denies it however he
doesn't pay any attention to what she is
saying busy on the phone with pam saw
asks him to stop pretending because she
feels the same way they both are in love
with someone else but are trying to do
the rational thing after a long
discussion ohm realizes that he has
never stopped loving pam since high
school he thanks saw for opening his
eyes to the truth and walks away the
next day he brings saw and her
colleagues to a club to thank her for
being such a good friend it just so
happens that bass is the singer at the
same club the owners organize a program
in which the customers will bid for a
kiss from bass the one with the highest
bid will win muhammad goes all out on
bidding but to his surprise pam who is
also at the club keeps raising the bid
at last maham wins but makes saw get the
reward although skeptical she goes to
the stage and shares a kiss with bass
right after he storms off and drives
away with pam when saw and om talk about
her it is disclosed that pam actually
works for bass's father somewhere else
she takes bass to his father the man
wants to send him to america for his
further studies against his wish bass is
taken outside where he meets saw she
tries to wipe the blood from his face
but bass turns around and gets inside
the car it drives away but sod doesn't
give up and follows bass makes the
driver stop and comes to her but only to
apologize and return back to the car at
last saw is left crying in the street
five years later she is still working
for the same company her life has
changed a lot but she still has not
forgotten bass one night she falls
asleep and dreams of him taking care of
her when she wakes up bass is actually
on her balcony he had kept the keys from
years ago and entered the apartment at
night terrifying saw touches his face
unable to believe that he is finally
back the movie ends as they embrace each
other subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching